zusammen und herzlich willkommen zum zdf
heute live eure mit ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen diskussionen und ereignissen
und der streit um den es heute geht der
ist schon mehr als 40 jahre alt aber
trotzdem ist er heute und diese dieser
woche hochaktuell denn es geht um die
große frage ob wir heute überhaupt noch
autobahnen brauchen und neue bauen
sollten und ob beim protest gegen diese
bauvorhaben eigentlich alle mittel recht
sind
der protest richtet sich derzeit gegen
den ausbau der a 49 in hessen und da
sieht es derzeit so aus wenn wir mal auf
die aktuellen bilder gesehen die uns
diese woche erreicht haben
seit einem jahr schon sind mittlerweile
aktivisten dort und dann rot grüner wald
bei marburg zugang haben sich dort
verschanzt haben die bäume besetzt
teilweise die polizei versucht sie
darunter zu holen
die räumung wird von noch ein paar tage
dauern es waren auch bekannte aktivist
innen dabei zum beispiel carola rakete
die ja auch bekannt ist durch ihre
seenotrettung im mittelmeer
die ganze aktion wird wohl noch ein paar
tage dauern vielleicht sogar wochen denn
die aktivistinnen haben sehr erfolgreich
den zugang zum wald blockiert und
darüber wollen wir heute diskutieren ob
das nötig ist oder nicht verschiedene
meinungen wie immer sehr gerne auch hier
in unseren kommentaren gesehen fragen
und so weiter immer wieder reinhauen und
gesprächen heute rechts neben ihr könnt
ihr sie schon sehen mit charisma von
traders fünf user und ein bisschen
später mit winfried becker landrat des
schwalm-eder-kreises direkt dort vor ort
betroffen
wir fangen aber bei der kritikerin an
und weil wir heute einen sehr
verschiedene generationen dabei haben
haben wir habe ich mich darauf geeinigt
mit mir selber dass ich beide
generationen sitze auch wenn es
vielleicht ein bisschen merkwürdig von
den ein oder anderen ins team das wir
nutzen die normalerweise immer alle aber
das ist für sie in ordnung braucht jedes
mal oder
also wir haben gerade gesehen es geht
darum einen streit ja schon sehr sehr
alt ist er ist älter als sie das auch
älter als ich über 40 jahre wird und
diesen ausbau gestritten
das ist bis vom
bundesverwaltungsgerichts hof gelandet
der hat gesagt das projekt ist so in
ordnung die klagen dagegen können wir
den kennen wir nicht stattgeben
was bringt es denn da noch sichtbar
jetzt im wald zu verschanzen seit über
einem jahr
also man muss tatsächlich bei dem urteil
des bundesverwaltungsgerichtes genau
angucken
das hat zwar auf der einen seite gesagt
ja wir können gerade an dieser stelle
juristisch mit dieser fragestellung die
daten heran getragen wurde nichts machen
grundsätzlich könnte man aber heute
diese autobahn nicht mehr bauen auf
basis des aktuellen rechts weil sich mit
europarechtlichen mit wasserschutz
berechtigten und verschiedenen anderen
umweltrichtlinien eigentlich ist das
nicht verein das ganze kann man aber so
zu sagen was juristisch behandelt wurde
ist okay dieser verkehrsplanern wurde
vor acht jahren glaube ich das letzte
mal überprüft da war das irgendwie noch
ok das zeigt aber schon die ganze
absurdität auch weil ihm sozusagen zu
sagen auf basis dessen was bei acht
jahren im norden war zu sagen ja das
macht man jetzt obwohl sich ganz ganz
viel drumherum geändert hat seit
eigentlich in den grundlegenden
konflikten die haben aber trotzdem muss
man ja sagen ist ein rechtsstaat da ist
geltendes recht angeordnet also
angewendet worden
das ist jetzt so lange dauert das
umzusetzen ist ja eine ganz andere
diskussion wir müssen uns ja daran
halten was damals beschlossen wurde und
wenn man bis zum
bundesverwaltungsgericht ruf geht dann
sind alle rechtsmittel ausgeschöpft
das kann man auch der einen stelle so
sagen aber dann müssen wir ja natürlich
weise alle verträge alle gesetze die es
weltweit gut durchrechnen und da schon
klar wir können das 1,5 grad ziel und
auch aktien nicht mehr einhalten
die hodzic verträge und gesetze diesen
quasi eine erhitzung von weit über zwei
grad jetzt schon ein stein und da ist
natürlich die frage okay wir haben
dieses beim klimaschutz abkommen ist
nicht so dass wir aktuell von page
abschnitt haben an verträgen angesetzten
kippen wir jetzt das ganz einfach unser
klima abkommen oder sagen wir okay wie
müssen wir dann im zweifel zwei mal
irgendwo neue gesetze machen irgendwo
verträge neu schreiben dass wir den ganz
ganz vielen anderen situationen ja auch
gemacht und ich glaube das ist was wo
wie viel er als demokratie sagen müssen
wie können wir schaffen damit eben den
umgang zu binden
bei eigentlich sollte das 15 grad ziel
dass bei dieser klimaabkommen was auch
im völkerrechtlichen vertrag ist ja den
rahmen bilden von allen verträgen und
gesetzt wie wir dachten was ja das ist
ja ein riesen prozess das dauert lange
dass das braucht viele ressourcen und
kräfte verschwenden sie die nicht gerade
dabei den das alles in einen ausbau von
gerade mal 60 kilometer autobahn
reinzustecken gibt es da nicht eben
größere räder die man drehen müsste also
diese sterne oder fonds der ist auf der
einen seite ist ein exemplarischer kampf
aber das muss man sich auch vor augen
halten dass geht hier nicht irgendwie so
60 kilometer autobahnen sondern es geht
um die generelle frage wie wollen wir
mobilität gestalten wie gehen wir
bereich mit sozusagen verträgen die vor
40 jahren geschlossen und wie gehen wir
damit um
wie gehen wir damit um in sachen mit der
ganzen frage nach mobilität wie gehen
wir mit ökosystemen die irgendwo auf der
kippe stehen und wo können wir zu wenig
sagen die können wir einschränken wir
können uns gemacht und wo sagen wir das
ist mitunter vereinbaren
das heißt auch wenn es irgendwie ersten
aussieht als würde es eigentlich um 60
kilometer autobahn liegen geht es im
zweifel sei viel viel mehr wenn es um
die ganz ganz große fragen wer
entscheidet über kritik wo liegt
eigentlich die macht und was ist die
gesamte rolle von paris und von der
unterschied klimaschutzabkommen und der
frage nach welche politik mitgemacht
gesehen so steht hier und es geht hier
um wirklich großer grundsatzfragen
grundsatzdiskussionen die sich alle in
diesem relativ kleinen kleinstück
autobahnen zusammen finden
wer jetzt nicht ganz im bild ist vorüber
da eigentlich gestritten wird für den
fassen wir jetzt mal bzw
mein kollege dominik löschmeister diesen
streit kurz zusammen
darum geht es den ausbau der a 49
zwischen gießen und kassel seit mehr als
40 jahren beschäftigt anwohner und
naturschützer das projekt vor allem der
abschnitt durch den dannen röder forst
ist umstritten 27 hektar wald sollen
gerodet werden mit 3 prozent aber ein
geringer teil der gesamtfläche
die autobahn soll eine entlastung
bringen für viele kleine orte die vom
schwerlastverkehr betroffen sind auch
für unternehmen in der region macht ein
bau der autobahn sind sie wären mit der
a49 besser erreichbar
für die autobahngegner aber geht es im
dann in rötha forst ums ganze einfach
wird die räumung des waldes nicht werden
sie sind entschlossen den weiterbau der
a49 noch zu stoppen
also da stehen sich die fronten relativ
unversöhnlich gegenüber wir wollen
versuchen das heute vielleicht ein
bisschen aufzulösen aber nochmal zu frau
redner von freddys for future wir sind
in berlin aufgewachsen kennen sie die
mobilitätsprobleme da im ländlichen raum
den demand die die menschen hier einfach
ganz akut haben wo man einfach fest
stellt okay hier fährt kein bus mehr ab
nach 17 uhr vorher ist er dreimal
gefahren wenn ich irgendwie was besorgen
will brauche ich ein auto und am besten
autobahn weil dann bin ich nicht stunde
unterwegs mal vielleicht nur eine halbe
die mobilitätsprobleme der menschen und
ich natürlich aber wir sprechen auch mit
ganz vielen menschen vor ort seit 40
jahren auch um 22 widerstand gegen gegen
diese autobahn ist ja nicht nur so als
würden jetzt aktivisten auch berlin
sagen wir finden dass du hoch sondern es
gibt einen ganz ganz breite widerstand
vor ort auch in den dörfern die sagen
wir wollen diese autobahn nicht wir
möchten dass diese weiter erhalten
bleibt
gerade bei dieser frage nachzumachen
verkehr wo gesagt wurde okay der
aktuelle lastverkehr ist in den dörfern
einfach laufstärke technisch
abgastechnik nicht zu halten daher die
möglichkeit hilfe einfach das ganze auf
die schiene zu verlagern das ist auch
das einzige was wirklich zukunftsfähig
ist wenn wir sagen wir nehmen mobilitäts
wenn du wirklich ernst dann müssen wir
gerade mit dem ganzen lkw verkehr auf
die schiene
das wäre ein ansatzpunkt wo man wirklich
direkt angefangen könnt und sagen könnte
man schließt eben genau die unternehmen
die vor ort sind an den güterverkehr
netz an
teilweise sind auch den euro also auf
den geländen vor ort sind auch die
bahnanschlüsse quasi schon vorhanden ist
eben nur noch um anschluss an das netz
und damit ließen sich sehr sehr viel
schon regeln es gibt sie sich auch gut
also es geht ja nicht um die große frage
wollen alten leuten vor ort ihr auto
wegnehmen
aber zu sagen wir ob man diesen ball der
ein riesiges ökosystem der auch das
wasser von einer knappen halbe million
menschen vor ort dafür sorgen dass das
grundwasser herz gehen jetzt zu boden
für eine autobahn ist im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert mitten in
der klimakrise ein absurd und da so
sehen das auch die menschen die sich
dort im wald seit einem jahr auf halten
es sollen bis zu 200 aktivistinnen seien
unterschiedlicher stärke
die haben sich dort im wald teilweise
wirklich häuslich niedergelassen wir
haben so eben mal eine skype verbindung
aufgebaut und uns das mal zeigen lassen
wie das dort aussieht in den häusern ich
hoffe wir haben diesen film beitrags in
der kürze noch zusammenbekommen ich
frage mal kurz in der regie ist er da
liegt vor dann bitte einmal abfeuern
gekauft
das ist halt jetzt dunkel wir haben ja
matratzenlager ja hier erkennt man nicht
so viel haben schöne fenster man kann
tagsüber sich schon rausgucken und wir
haben hier so bei einem sehr premium
wolken wobei man auf den balkon gehen
hier kann man so ein bisschen rum gucken
da hinten sieht man die lichter von den
lichtmasten die die polizei aufgestellt
hat hier können wir sehen das ist
unrechtmäßig kleiner erst an dieser
eiche wo wir uns drauf befinden in den
balkon also das relativ große das
baumhaus und stilistisch ganz gut
aushalten oder richtig weder schauen
also wenn wie das zuhause von ganz
vielen lebewesen und eben auch von
menschen
stück für stück aufgefressen wird von
einigen maschinen die zeit um richtig
kassen komplexer zerstörung sind und
zwar für eine autobahn jahr 2020 keine
aufwerten sondern eher eine andere art
zusammenleben also einen ziemlich
beeindruckende protest wenn man das so
sehen möchte zumindest menschen die da
sehr viel aufopfern
aber wir sehen auch hier im chat frau
diesmal viel unverständnis muss ich
sagen ich nehme hier einen kommentar auf
von olaf eckel den ich gerade noch hatte
vielleicht finde ich ihn ich muss mal
kurz ein bisschen scrollen
der sagte da also ihr wollt eure rechte
also in richtung umweltschutz
aktivistinnen das ist demokratie ihr
wollt demonstrieren das ist euer recht
demokratie hat aber es ist auch die
demokratie dass die a49 gebaut wird das
gilt es zu akzeptieren und mit
demokratie und zivilem ungehorsam hat es
nichts mehr zu tun wenn man andere
schädigt die polizei angreift böller
steine oder gar italien wirft und
beleidigt das gehört bestraft
da ist also wirklich jemand relativ
ungehalten mit dieser form des protestes
da ist doch mal eine frage gibt es da
keine sorge dass dieses ja
nachvollziehbare anliegen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir nicht in der klimakrise
untergehen durch solche protestaktionen
wirklich auch schaden nimmt das für
menschen gibt die sagen sorry da gegner
mit ich da wir hier werden gerade an ich
weiß nicht ob herr also dass wir mit mir
auf der tabelle man bald war und den
protest vor ort miterlebt hat weiß was
wir erleben ist ein sehr großer starker
und friedlicher protest von leuten aus
allen bereichen der gesellschaft auch
ganz ganz weit aus der zivilgesellschaft
um eltern mit kindern die zu den wald
spazieren kommen vielleicht nicht in den
wald wohnen weil es nicht möglich ist
aber wirklich alles von zweijährigen
kindern bis hin zu irgendwie 80-jährigen
großeltern ist da alles dabei und wir
leben sehr breiten friedlichen protests
deswegen da man hat weil man dazwischen
gehen sorry ich habe in der wortmeldung
von olaf dudek ich habs jetzt ehrlich
gesagt nicht überprüft ich nehme das
einfach mal auf den stream auf der
schreibt aus der aktuellen pressemeldung
der polizei bei der absuche nach
gefahrenquellen entdeckten die
einsatzkräfte auf einem waldweg mit laub
bedeckten michael bretter mit langen
spitzen nach oben
wie gesagt ich kann das gerade nicht
verifizieren weil das kommt gerade rein
aber wenn das der fall sein sollte ist
dass friedlicher protest wie sie es
gesagt haben ich kann dazu gar nicht
sagen ich bin nicht bereit und bald ich
kann zu der sache keine stellung nehmen
müssen was dann tatsächlich die
situation ist und das kann ich jetzt
noch mal andere frage die sich um diesen
protest richtet mit welchen konsequenzen
haben die aktivisten zu rechnen ich
glaube die können wir jetzt nicht
beantworten aber wovon leben die
eigentlich also wie werden die da
versorgt es sehr unterschiedlich es gibt
teilweise aktivisten die also ganz
unterschied nicht von spenden über leute
die
seit irgendwie auch arbeiten zwar ganz
viel unterstützung natürlich auch aus
der zivilgesellschaft von vor ort in
form von sachspenden in form von leuten
die für eine kurze zeit bei valcom
unterstützen
sehr viele unterschiedliche arten
zweimal zwei leute die vorher für eine
zeit gegen geld gearbeitet haben sondern
gemacht haben geld mitbringen konnten
auch sehr divers so bis hierhin haben
wir miteinander geredet wir wollen
gleich auch noch mal 1 dreier gespräch
gehen
vielen dank bis hierhin ich möchte aber
mich noch mal kurz an unsere zuschauer
innen richten auch wenn es hier jetzt
wieder ein sehr emotionales thema für
manche ist bitte ich doch wirklich sehr
darum das ist auch sachlich und zivil
zugeht sich hier gegenseitig zu
beleidigen oder auch unsere
gesprächspartnerin zu beleidigen ist
nicht das was wir wollen und da werden
wir auch dementsprechend gegen vorgehen
so jetzt möchte ich aber einmal
weiterschalten zu jemandem der mit
diesem protest wahrscheinlich in dieser
form auch nicht so richtig einverstanden
ist uns zumindest sich schon sehr lange
dafür einsetzt dass diese a49 so gebaut
wird wie sie jetzt beschlossen ist das
system trifft becker sie sind oder ihr
sie nehmen mir landrat des
schwalm-eder-kreises von der spd also
direkt betroffenen vor ort sie kämpfen
schon lange für diese
autobahnverlängerung wenn sie die bilder
jetzt gerade von den protestierenden von
den aktivistinnen aus dem wald sehen was
denken sie da wir haben 40 jahre in der
tat eine diskussion um diese a49 um den
lückenschluss zur a 5 es hat
entsprechende entscheidungen gegeben auf
landes- und auch auf bundesebene auch
richterliche entscheidung
höchstrichterliche entscheidung und
prozess ist immer in ordnung wenn er
friedlich vonstatten geht aber man muss
auch zu einem gewissen zeitpunkt
akzeptieren dass eine entscheidung
gefallen ist und auch von den höchsten
gerichten überprüft worden ist und diese
entscheidung als richtig brutal
abgeurteilt wurde und insofern jetzt
auch der lückenschluss darauf und der
autobahn erfolgen kann
das heißt also so was wie ich sie bei
demonstrationen sonntagsspaziergänge vor
ort finden sie in ordnern sich dort im
wald in den bäumen zu verschanzen und
dafür zu sorgen dass nicht abgeholzt
werden kann finden sie nicht in ordnung
nein das gibt mir ein stück weit zu weit
zumal so besteht protest entwickelt ja
auch dinge passieren jemand nicht nur
friedlichen protest letztendlich nach
gleichsetzen kann
bei den polizeieinsätzen die stattfinden
wenn ich an die letzten vorkommnisse mit
fäkalien denke wenn ich an die
abseilaktion von autobahnbrücken denke
oder auch das abseilen aktivisten durch
die polizei von den bäumen geht es auch
um gefährdungen von anderen menschen
auch von unseren polizistinnen und
polizisten
das geht mir deutlich ein stück zu weit
ich kann das ja gerade nochmal
einschieben meine kollegin hinten im
hintergrund haben das einmal für mich
gecheckt vielen dank dafür also das mit
den nagel brettern hat die polizei
tatsächlich vermeldet ist aus einer
pressemitteilung der polizei
mittelhessen ich zitiere mal daneben
wurden bretter mit nägeln und eine
ausgehobene mit laub abgedeckte grube
gefunden welche vermutlich als
fahrzeughalle ausgehoben wurde so wenn
wir vielleicht mal aber jetzt auch
tatsächlich diese diskussion die
autobahn noch mal zurückkommen
herr becker warum ist die ihnen jetzt so
wichtig dass man immer noch daran
festhält
momentan soll der ganze verkehr über die
bundesstraße 3 die geht quer durch den
schwalm-eder-kreis das heißt wir haben
momentan die a 49
januar bis 9 tal bis die chancen gebaut
danach soll der verkehr über die b 3 der
regel schon ab waren
und das bedeutet eine riesige belastung
für die menschen an die entlang der p3
wohnen an der b3 wollen
der tod der gesamte schwerlastverkehr
durch dort entstehen riesige
lärmbelastungen belastungen durch
gestand wollte überörtliche verkehr
durch und diese menschen waren seit
jahren jahrzehnten auf den bau auf den
lückenschluss der a 49 damit sie endlich
auch ein leben ohne diese wenn sie
verkehrsbelastung führen würden das ist
ja auch schon nachvollziehbar haben sie
doch gerade gehört dass das frau den
smart von fredericia auch nachvollziehen
kann aber 40 jahre gegenwehr und protest
und jetzt auch im endeffekt ein plan wo
man sagen würde das würde heute so nicht
mehr gebaut
kann man da nicht auch einfach mal sagen
okay wir haben es versucht wir müssen
uns was anderes ausdenken
es ist 40 jahre keine alternative
letztendlich gefunden worden und ich
will das auch noch mal deutlich sagen
wir haben als stadt agra ist eine
riesige fläche sind der zweitgrößte
flächenkreis in hessen und die
möglichkeit der menschen an zentren zu
gelangen also verkehrlich angebunden zu
sein ist ausgesprochen eingeschränkt bei
uns bei uns fährt eben nur alle zwei
stunden ein bus und wir haben in diesen
ortschaften keine bahnanbindung aber das
geld aufnehmen um dafür zu sorgen dass
das dann gibt diese bahnanbindungen zu
bauen zum beispiel auch auf
bahnanbindungen dafür müssen sie flächen
haben dafür müssen sie bald wurden
das lässt sich in der form im schwalm
eder kreis in der fläche überhaupt nicht
spielen
das hat doch erst mal interessante
diskussion da würde ich gerne frauen
haben auch mal dazu holen
da ist sie im zweier sehr schön rentner
wie ist denn das ist es okay für bahn
also für eine bahntrasse wald abzuholzen
und für eine autobahn nicht ist dass der
kompromiss oder ist das überhaupt jetzt
einen weg wo man sagen würde okay da
damit lag sie mit uns reden fragen zu
beantworten ja banker zum beispiel damit
an der banken oder fonds ist ja am
anfang des jahres ganz vielen gründen
noch zusätzlich zu der tatsache dass es
darum geht dass werden geht es auch
darum da sind sehr wertvolle ökosysteme
vor ort wir haben ein wasserschutzgebiet
unter diesen wald sozusagen der dieses
diesen gesamte weiter system noch mal
viel viel wertvoller macht deswegen kann
man da keine super schalen glaube ich
aussagen treffen zu ja das geht immer
oder nein das geht nie was aber klar ist
bei abzuholzen und intaktes ökosystem
zerstören im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert um eine autobahn zu bauen wo
wir wissen dass mehr straßen immer zu
mir motorisierten verkehr hören das ist
auf jeden fall nicht akzeptabel dass man
für die dann wiederum mobilitäts wende
fördern kann
auch natürlich flächen braucht und
gucken muss okay wie kann man das
möglichst im rahmen von allen
ökologischen begrenzen wir haben im
rahmen von wir wollen keine lücke system
zerstören machen das dann wieder was wo
man sich neu planen muss das kann ich
als studentin jetzt nicht einfach
übernehmen dafür gibt es leute die
können das die wissen genau aber
tendenziell höre ich da eher wohlwollen
in die richtung zu denken als in
richtung autobahn airbag haben wir
gerade gehört auch von frau rehns mal
öfter schon mal das wort schutz wasser
also es gibt dort schutz im gebiet wo
wasser wasserschutzgebiet ist das was
ich gesagt habe
machen sie sich da überhaupt keine
sorgen dass ihr grund und trinkwassers
natürlich hat grundwasser oberstes gebot
das ist ja alles mit untersucht worden
und es gibt im bau der autobahn für die
versiegelung der flächen für die
eingriff in die natur auch weitreichend
ausgleichsmaßnahmen die die hier auch
mit parallel vollzogen werden
um den eingriff dann auch letztendlich
wieder zu 100 prozent auszugleichen ist
das nicht was ihnen reicht frau wir
jetzt mal dass man zumindest sagte wir
sind ja in deutschland der relativ weit
die wird ja nicht im amazonas einfach
abgeholzt und das wird nicht wieder
aufgeforstet sondern es wird etwas
weggenommen und woanders versuchen einen
ausgleich zu schaffen
jetzt ist der ton gerade weg 300 jahre
alten eichen und anderen bäumen dafür
jetzt irgendwo neue junge kiefern zu
pflanzen wird dieses ökosystem nicht
ersetzen
und was tatsächlich auch wenn man sich
das urteil des bundesverwaltungsgerichts
aber dass er gerne entsprochen wird noch
mal anguckt ist dass das auch genau
aussagen auf basis der heutigen
wasserschutz gesetze dürfte diese
autobahn sind nicht mehr gebaut werden
unabhängig von ausgleichsmaßnahmen und
das ist ja eigentlich das aufgrund
dessen wir unsere entscheidung treffen
sollten die entscheidung also dass es
bundesweit ist nicht extra noch mal in
seiner entscheidung so ich guck mal
einfach in die kommentare war das bei
uns ja auch sehr wichtig ist die
zuschauerinnen mit einzubinden
hier gibt es natürlich sehr kontroverse
meinungen ich sage mal einmal hier von
waltraud war ich lese ich mal vor auf
facebook sie sagt natürlich brauchen wir
autobahn viele tausende menschen müssen
mit dem auto zur arbeit fahren da keine
züge oder busse fahren ist es unzumutbar
durch orte durch zu fahren oder auf
landstraßen um zu zuckeln jeder möchte
pünktlich zu arbeiten schnell nach hause
kommen denn nicht jeder wohnt in
großstädten aber es gibt auch die
gegenmeinung genau die schließen sich
quasi bei face of future an von matthias
mundil auf facebook heutzutage natur für
eine autobahn platz zu machen ist leider
totaler schwachsinn
herr becker ist das nicht auch eine
position wo man einfach sagen muss ok
vor 40 jahren hatten wir noch einen
anderen ansatz dass umweltschutz angeht
unser klima sah noch anders aus obwohl
viele schon wussten das ändert sich oder
das befürchtet haben wir haben ein
pariser klimaschutzabkommen das hat's
noch gerade schon zitiert wir müssen
jetzt einfach mal um herrn wieland von
gestern im rk ii zu zitieren die
arschbacken zusammenkneifen und uns was
anderes ausdenken
ich habe tatsächlich eine große rad
drehen
ja ich bin natürlich auch überzeugt
davon dass ich mobilität verändern muss
wir brauchen neue mobilitätsformen in
form von neuer antriebstechnik die die
verbrenner auf dauer letztendlich
ersetzen wird ab den ich auch persönlich
überzeugt sein denn der
schadstoffausstoß durch mobilität ist
natürlich extrem
und insofern musste eine eine
verkehrswende herbei aber die menschen
in ländlichen regionen haben natürlich
auch anspruch auf mobilität auf die
möglichkeit in angemessenen zeiten an
den nächsten ort zu kommen um
einzukaufen um zum arzt zu gehen und und
und das müssen wir auch im ländlichen
raum gewährleisten und der ländliche
raum aus mobilität ist ein wichtiges gut
im ländlichen raum und da spielt
natürlich auch die a49 der lückenschluss
zwar fünfter maßgebliche rolle der
straße die frage wird sein ob wir die
momentanen antriebstechniken auf auf
dauer so betreiben wollen
erdöl ist letztendlich auch endlich und
da brauchen wir in der tat eine
mobilitäts wende wir brauchen neue
antriebstechnik neuer antriebsformen
aber die mobilität selber die
möglichkeit dass mobilität wird auf
dauer auch in sämtlichen räumen bleiben
ist aber ist das nicht eine aussicht
frau reden zahlen dass man sagt okay
verbrennungsmotoren von denen
verabschieden wir uns über kurz oder
lang sowieso die einen länder machen
noch schneller
hier könnte es ein bisschen zügiger
gehen in deutschland dann brauchen diese
menschen anbindungen und wenn die dann
klimaneutral sich fortbewegen können ist
doch so eine autobahn dann schon wieder
auch okay
[Musik]
mehr als eine reine anfangs wende
natürlich wird niemand spricht davon von
heute auf morgen und auch nicht alle
autos abzuschaffen aber was glas ist das
aktuelle die aktuelle menge an autos auf
deutschen straßen fahren ist nicht
nachhaltig und kann nicht nachhaltig
sein
deswegen muss verkehrswende auch immer
eine mobilitäts wende sein und muss zum
beispiel gerade wenn wir uns im
güterverkehr angucken der ja eine frage
rund um die a 49 in ganz ganz
entscheidender faktor ist wenn man sich
das anguckt der verkehr der durch die
dörfer gerade volt ist ja insbesondere
der hüter verkennen starke belastung
denen auch die schiene zu verlagern
werden ganz ganz essentieller teil im
bereich dieser mobilitäts wände und
daher sozusagen neben die a49 damit die
eltern nicht in dollar sondern auch
diese ausgebrannt war
dann können es einfach der falsche
ansatz sondern da muss es darum gehen
den güterverkehr auf der schiene zu
verlagern damit auch eben endlich raum
zu entlasten und das passiert nicht das
anbauen weil wir wissen dass autobahn
immer zu mehr verkehr führen
einer gegen antwort herr becker wir
können ja gerne mal versuchen alles das
was vor allem wieder verkehr auf der
straße haben auf die bahn zu verlagern
dafür reichen die kapazitäten bei weitem
nicht aus und es müsste das barnes
siemens ausgebaut werden
also eine hundertprozentige verlagerung
oder weiters weist ihr müsste
verlagerung von der straße auf die auf
skifahren ist im moment bei sind jetzt
halt vorhandenen kapazitäten überhaupt
nicht möglich aber da hat muss man doch
feststellen einfach dass in den letzten
20 30 jahren wirklich am falschen ende
gespart wurde dass die infrastruktur der
bahn dass er nicht genug in dreien will
investiert wurde und dass man da jetzt
eigentlich das geld reinstecken müssen
und vielleicht nicht den autobahnen
das hätte vielleicht die letzten 20
jahre zu passieren müssen das vermag ich
auch nicht zu beurteilen
aber momentan gebe es die kapazitäten
jedenfalls nicht das kann ich
feststellen dass das wissen wir
es darf was sollen diese vorliegen
entzieht sich meiner weiter brutal sind
ja merke ich das ist auch jetzt mal was
ein gegner möchte doch genau der punkt
wo wir angefangen wir sind wenn wir
jetzt sagen unseren güterverkehrs
märkten verschiedene apps nicht
ausreichend aufgebaut das fehlen in
vielen ländlichen regionen auch
personenverkehr auch überall aufbauten
dann müssen wir noch jetzt da an warum
zu sagen wenn wir wirklich eine
verkehrswende erreichen wollen eine
mobilität zu ende da unser geld
reinzustecken und nicht weiter in die
aufrechterhaltung eines systems wo wir
alle wissen das ist nicht nachhaltig ist
und wir alle wissen dass es zu viele
autos sind die auf deutschen straßen
fahren
das ist zu viel für ein treffen stillens
darf ist stau überall beurteilt das ist
auch nicht lebensqualität steigern im
stau zu stehen
so und jetzt zu sagen wir brauchen
deswegen mehr autobahn um dieses system
aufrecht zu erhalten haben damit er
weniger geld ausgeben zweifelsfall den
ausbau von schienenstrecken das
erscheint mir total kurth ich habe ihren
beitrag auf youtube bin ich noch mal
ganz gerne ein werfen wollen würde von
duran duran bei den können wir auch mal
auf meinem rechner sich uns angucken da
ist er schreibt oder sie schreiben das
kann ich gerade nicht sehen sich auf
eine freiwillige verkehrswende zu
verlassen und trotzdem die autobahnen zu
bauen funktioniert nicht man muss als
regierung alternativen fördern und das
ist tatsächlich jetzt aber auch ein
streit der dreht sich geht bis in die
bundesebene natürlich rein ist das eine
bundesautobahn die gebaut wird
da sind die grünen vor allem sehr munter
dabei sich gegenseitig zu streiten weil
es da einfach sehr unterschiedliche
ansichten gibt vor allem die frage ob
das was jetzt geltendes recht ist das
haben wir soeben schon mal diskutiert
jetzt einfach doch durchgezogen werden
muss oder ob man jetzt sagen muss das
geht heute nicht mehr was frau wir uns
ja auch schon anfangs gesagt hat und wir
hatten gestern ihren heute schon mal bei
den kollegen herrn harbeck zu gast
chef der bundes grünen und der hat zu
diesem streit folgendes gesagt ich bin
voll dabei zu sagen wir müssen schneller
radikaler dinge ändern allerdings im
rechtsstaat und das ist ja nun ein
anderes problem unserer zeit dass der
rechtsstaat angegriffen wird kann es nur
über rechtsstaatliche mittel gehen
das heißt gesetze müssen geändert werden
man kann sich nicht über die gesetze
stellen
stellen sie sich vor es wäre anders rum
ein minister eine ministerin würde sagen
das passt mir in den kram was mit seinen
ökologischen grünen mehrheiten
beschlossen wurde ich halte mich da
nicht dran
wir hatten chaos dagegen wir amerika gar
nichts insofern muss die radikale
forderung zu einer radikalen
umgestaltung der rechtlichen grundlagen
führen das ist das ist die demokratische
aufgabe vor der wir stehen
soweit also robert habeck hätte das wort
hat die bundesvorsitzende von bündnis 90
die grünen gestern zum heute journal vor
ihm hat er nicht einen punkt dass man
einfach akzeptieren muss das ist
geltendes recht das müssen wir die
gesetze ändern dafür brauchen wir eine
mehrheit in den regierungen und dann
kann man das tatsächlich auch nachhaltig
tun und nicht indem man sich im wald
verschanzt ich habe tatsächlich aus dem
ende ihrer frage nicht gehört kann nur
zum ersten teil antworten ich glaube ich
schaffe es auch schon mal anfangs
erzielen die sache ist die wenn wir uns
alle verträge und alle gesetze die es
aktuell gibt angucken
auch ihren sozusagen carbon footprint
hin dann haben wir lange schon dass er
zeit 2 grad zieht einfach über
überreichte wir haben werden einfach
damit viel mehr co2 und treibhausgase
ausstoßen als im rahmen dieser
klimaabkommens dürfen
und deswegen müssen wir jetzt irgendwann
anfangen zu sagen okay dass man unser
klima abkommen setzt uns aber nun mal
eben diesen physikalischen rahmen von
was können wir als gesellschaft was
können wir als weltgemeinschaft
aushalten und klimaschäden an
klimafolgen da setzt unseren rahmen wie
können wir da drin unsere gesetze eben
machen welche verträge müssen wir
vielleicht auch kündigen welche gesetze
müssen wir verändern und das machen wir
in einem rechtsstaat am ganz ganz vielen
stellen immer wieder dass gesetze
verändert werden weil sie nicht mehr
zeitgemäß und weil sich die umstände
verändert haben und das ist
der bäcker ist das rad und frau geben
zwar ein bisschen störtebeker ich würde
mal
ich glaube sie haben punkt gemacht vor
ihnen gibt es meiner becker weiter
machen sie sich eigentlich keine sorgen
dass ihre enkel oder enkel oder urenkel
sie in 20 30 jahren fragen hofer warum
hast du das eigentlich damals nicht
verhindert und hast genau zusammen mit
friends noch an falls der user versucht
die sachen anders zu gestalten
sehen sie wir machen bei uns im
schwalm-eder-kreis seit ganz ganz vielen
jahren sehr aktive klimapolitik vom
ausbau der windkraft wir sanieren unsere
gebäude wir wollen über kurz oder lang
in den nächsten jahren auch bei uns im
landkreis das kreiseigene gebäude an die
klimaneutral sein wird wir machen als
kreispolitik für alle parteigrenzen
hinweg da wirklich sehr sehr viel
aber ihr geht es auch um den schutz der
menschen deshalb 40 jahren auf dieser
autobahn wagen und die erfüllung eines
klimaabkommens wird nicht an den
lückenschluss der a 49 hängen sondern
hier geht es um den tisch den schutz der
menschen die entlang der b3 wohnen hier
geht es um die frage von mobilität im
ländlichen raum
und hier gibt es entscheidungen des
deutschen bundestag dass sie gibt es
entscheidungen des hessischen landtags
der jeweilige regierung und der
entsprechenden gerichte und insofern
haben wir einen punkt jetzt erreicht wo
die demokratie entschieden hat dass
dieser autobauer nach 40 jahren jetzt
endlich erfolgen kann soll und kann und
deswegen erwarte ich auch dass nach
diesem demokratischen prozess dafür dann
auch dieses jahr akzeptiert wird so
freigiebig weiter an frau diesmal wird
das akzeptiert dann sind wir gespannt
wie die nächsten tage
wochen und vielleicht monate sich
entwickeln bis anfang des nächsten
jahres hat ja tatsächlich dann die
regierung zeit dort im wald zu holzen
dann ist wieder schulzeit das gibt es ja
auch bei uns
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen frau wir uns
noch unter ihnen herr becker für die
diskussion dass sie sich dargestellt
haben und bedanke mich bei euch und bei
ihnen im stream für die kommentare und
für die fragen zu diesem schwierigen
thema wir werden über das thema
umweltschutz klimaschutz und wie
schaffen wir die mobilitäts wende hier
noch sehr oft diskutieren hab ich das
gefühl für heute sagen wir einfach mal
das war es vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit bis zum nächsten mal
und tschüss